last point it's not a question to
request oh gosh the seven-year
anniversary of the percy harvin trade i
want you to look into the camera and say
we have no intent to trade Stefon Diggs
will you do that for me
Stefon Diggs at a Minnesota Viking
oh that ended up being that was Rick
Spearman with this a little more than
six weeks ago at the Scouting Combine
for the world turned upside down
the Vikings turned upside down
offensively with that trade that sent
Stefon Diggs to the Buffalo Bills for a
first-round pick a fifth round pick and
a sixth round pick this year and a
fourth round pick next year so let's
start on our NFC North draft needs Chris
the Minnesota Vikings cannot leave the
draft that begins two weeks from today
without what Vikings got a lot of work
to do all right that's the first thing I
know for sure I mean I mean what are the
offseason so far but I think the thing I
look at more than anything with Mike
Zimmer all right it's debatable Mike
what is it it's a DB or a wide receiver
that jumps out to me it's one of those
two and I would say they got to come
away in this draft with a DB I mean
losing you know McKenzie Alexander trae
Wayne and Xavier Rhodes all gone Mike
Zimmer is a defensive coach you know I
got to think that's priority number one
for this Minnesota Vikings team that has
a bunch of holes to fill in their roster
right now yeah look I think they'll be
fine at defensive back because Mike
Zimmer and Rick's film and do a nice job
of finding talented guys wherever they
may be including a Holton Hill who was
undrafted and coaching them up into
better players than maybe they would
have been I'm comfortable with Mike
Hughes and Holton Hill assuming that
Hughes can stay healthy and he'll can
stay on the right side of the league's
substance abuse and other policies he
got a PE d so you're not you can't be
that comfortable with them you just said
it well well but I'm comfortable that
the Vikings will find guys somehow some
way who can come in and be post up and
play I'm far more concerned about the
offensive line
Chris because the thing about Kirk
Cousins is very simple Kirk Cousins is
adept at running the play that is called
when the world begins to crumble around
him Kirk Cousins is not skilled when it
comes to improvising when it comes to
the second play you know with Patrick
mahomes there's the play that they want
him to run
then there's the play that he later
decides he has to run when the first
play falls apart Kirk Cousins doesn't
have that in his tool bag so the
offensive line needs to hold together
long enough to let Kirk Cousins deliver
the football to whoever is open and I'm
not concerned about the receiver
position because they love BC Johnson
Adam Phelan is still one of the best
receivers in the NFL
Irv Smith tight end they drafted last
year he can step up as a pass catcher
this year Kyle Rudolph is still there
they'll be fine
if Kirk Cousins can deliver the football
to whoever is open the key to me is the
offensive line has to be good enough to
allow Cousins to do and I still think
the offensive lines are work in progress
well yeah it's not the best offensive
line in football that's for sure I you
know and yeah I hear you improvements
need to be made for the future and depth
and everything like that but it's still
a solid unit I mean they could run the
football and Kirk Cousins you're right
he's not going to be that type of guy so
it'd be interesting I'm actually shocked
that you went that way I thought you
were going to want to want to replace
Stefon Diggs and get a receiver in the
draft Mike now look and they have found
their best receivers late in the draft
or undrafted like an Adam feeling every
time they roll the dice on a first-round
guy a high round guy it ends up being a
disappointment so I'm not saying they
shouldn't draft any receivers I just
don't think that it's top priority with
those two first round picks I'd use both
of those first-round picks on offensive
lineman all right the Packers can't
leave the draft without what a speed
receiver can we please give Aaron
Rodgers a speed damn receiver okay I
mean when I look at the Packers the only
thing I really look at okay I'm their
team hey yes offensive line you know
they're gonna have to watch and start
building that pocket er he's going to
the last year of his contract they gotta
upgrade their the re box er gulag
is gone so there's things like that what
I like to see them get bigger in the
middle of their defense sure but I know
a speed receiver yes they need somebody
opposite of Davante Adams I know they
signed Devin Funchess and I like that
because Rodgers can throw two big guys
and he's a great back shoulder thrower
but they need a guy that scares defenses
and opens up Devin funk dish and Avante
Adams and lets a bond to Adams run all
this nuance route running so that to me
I mean I've been starving that for that
for for Aaron Rodgers for six years now
so I would like to see that happen I
agree with you there nothing more for me
to say when it comes to the Packers the
Bears can't leave the draft without what
yeah the Bears you know it's an
interesting discussion the defense is
signed in my opinion maybe they could
use a corner but I think they got some
corners there they signed already burns
they got a kid coliver who's really good
opposite of fuller you know I think that
they're okay they're they might need
some depth I think the biggest thing
with the Bears that is unimpressive to
me is their tackle play their tackle
play last year it was horrible you know
they got some good guys in the middle as
far as Daniels at guard and Cody white
hair who played they're both kind of a
guard center combination but their
tackles who just yeah and they're
getting up there in age and they didn't
play that well I know they some signed
Jermaine a Fetty but I think tackle is
the biggest thing going forward for this
bears team they got to come out with one
in the second or third round of this
draft they don't have many picks you say
all the time that quarterbacks get too
much money they get too much praise
they're too much focus but here's the
thing when the quarterback doesn't play
well the quarterback gets dumped on when
the reality is maybe he's not playing
well because they don't have any time to
demand by the offense right the
offensive line needs to be there for
Mitchell drew Biscay nick foles whoever
ends up behind center for the Chicago
Bears all right the Detroit Lions can't
leave the draft without what Chris so
you were agreeing with me with the Bears
thing you think it's offensive yeah yeah
it is
yeah and they couldn't run the ball it
was crap alright the Detroit Lions I
mean this is an easy one to Matt
Patricia is a defensive head coach their
butts are on the line there this year
they were the worst past defensive
football last year they lost Darius
Leigh they need corner
Bax badly they need an elite cornerback
now I don't know if you take one a pick
number three I know a lot of people
think like they might take the Ohio
State kid Okuda at number three I'd be a
little scared with any corner that's an
island corner that runs in the high four
fours I don't know if that's worth
number three I think the Lions can be a
trade down team but cornerback and
multiple ones Mike I think have to be on
the Raider for the for the radar for the
Lions for as bad as their past defense
was last year and of course we know they
want to play a lot of man-to-man because
this is Bill Belichick Matt Patricia
defense
I want impact player up front and where
the Lions are drafting should put them
in position to get one I'm I'm tempted
if I'm the Lions to trade down yeah but
but I don't want to blow the shot at
getting somebody who can come in and be
a difference maker right away it's kind
of what Ron Rivera was talking about
with Washington with the second overall
pick you can get a great player like a
chase young you trade down do you get
that player who's gonna come in make a
huge difference a Knick Bosa type of a
difference right away that can transform
a team that's what the Lions need they
need one guy who was gonna get they do
and have the kind of impact that Nick
Bosa had for the 49ers last year because
that's the that's the guy who's going to
save jobs in Detroit because the heat is
on Matt Patricia and GM Bob Quinn in
2020
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports